para sus partidarios giorgia meloni es
la política que va a ser más fuerte a
italia una líder joven y mediática con
un origen de clase trabajadora a muchos
les gustaría verla como primera ministra
pero para otros meloni es motivo de
profunda preocupación dado los vínculos
de su partido con el fascismo meloni
abordó esta controversia a principios de
agosto negando las afirmaciones de que
sería un peligro para la democracia vino
fratelli mitad leído que una victoria de
los hermanos e italia en las elecciones
de septiembre significaría un desastre
que llevaría a un giro autoritario a la
salida de italia del euro y otras
tonterías de ese tipo
swartz nada nada de eso es cierto
melón y se involucró en la política
desde muy joven se unió a la juvenil del
movimiento socialista italiano
neofascista cuando tenía 15 años en 2006
fue elegida diputada y dos años más
tarde se convirtió en ministra de la
juventud bajo el mandato de silvio
berlusconi a sus 31 años era la persona
más joven en ocupar un puesto en el
gabinete en 2012 cuando la derecha
italiana empezó a fracturarse melón y co
fundó un nuevo movimiento político
hermanos de italia se convirtió en
presidenta del partido en 2014 y se le
atribuye el mérito de haber catapultado
el grupo de la extrema derecha
algo que sin duda dará a los hermanos de
italia una ventaja en las próximas
elecciones es el hecho de que fueron la
única fuerza política significativa que
se mantuvo al margen del gobierno de
mario draghi melón y se ha negado a
ceder y se ha mantenido coherente en lo
que respecta a la política su partido
mantiene una postura dura contra la
inmigración y los derechos de la
comunidad lgtb más además quiere reducir
los impuestos y acabar con el programa
de ayudas a los desempleados
según los últimos sondeos si hermanos de
italia forma coalición de derechas con
los partidos de la liga y fuerza
italiana tiene muchas posibilidades de
conseguir suficientes votos para formar
gobierno